hey guys it's dregg here and it John is
this here before anyone asks yes black
nail polish a little bit of eyeliner one
day more sinister a dolphin rag check
out a photo of my user or a gal but yeah
yeah yeah oh yeah we're doing spider-man
homecoming what
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
YouTube what are you doing in the Roman
army and civil war person s gosh I
missed it me feeling super super we do
the same okay I'm gonna get hold of all
of you how dare you disagree Oh surprise
another happening what are you hiding
oh you know just the other day I was
telling John how I don't have been
excited when I see some of these
trailers when I was like reflecting on
the spider-man homecoming trailers we've
got and I've been feeling like I don't
really know what they have to offer that
that unique like it looks good but it
doesn't look like it's that unique yeah
this right here I was watching this who
thinking like you know what I could use
from this movie it's kind of a scene
yeah yeah then as I keep going like oh
we're getting pretty much a seat yeah I
know that's tremendous choice yeah this
part I think that felt very differ from
all the other spider-man movies you've
gotten it yeah and I thought about that
none point of you made two because you
know like looking at this trailers the
things I'm least excited for about this
or like you know the Tony Stark vids and
the action just because like I know that
stuff yeah we're you know it's going to
be good and the thing I'm most excited
to see about this is the Peter Parker
story is him and his friend and in him
at school and all that simply the first
time I'm just most excited about that
Side Story and that scene really made it
seem like they got there their dynamic
and their comedy in there yeah well on
that the tone of that scene was great
you do see a different side we haven't
gone in a scene like that yeah elbows of
a Spider Man revealing himself to the to
a degree like that word it was that
funny
let's to get a couple of things is kind
of funny to me how I don't know how
Peter just I guess I could see how he
didn't notice he was there because he
was intelligent going to be there yeah
could you think would like spidey senses
in peripheral you might have noticed him
a little bit besides that but I thought
that I actually thinking about that when
they did the reverse shot they showed
like the bunk bed and like him kind of
off in the corner I was like okay yeah
it was enough that I could forget if he
was I mean I could get it cuz he was
just focused on closing the door so and
they wouldn't notice him yeah and I
expecting him to be there yeah but even
that little effect of him like going
through the window going up on the
ceiling swelling
the windows it split with my foot and
closing the door the cold crawling part
so it's really good yeah it looks really
like great wire effects oh look like a
guy who's really just crumbling on the
ceiling at that point like you know
maybe when I think of what turned upside
down like that you know he can't be
upside down with the way how it was shot
and everything oh you're right yeah good
that's what I mean it's a lot of movies
do like an uptick lighten up or they
cheat the shot to make it look like he's
crawling here it was like oh it really
just did some good effects wire effects
are he can crawl yeah so that was
awesome Ned leads at this trailer did
something for me where I got excited for
you Carrie
huh I'm more excited to see Ned leaves
than I am to see Michael Keaton playing
the vulture right now you seemed really
funny I love that touch of like you know
I got to be honest is like yeah it was
kind of have teenagers and I respond to
the situation at hand right yeah yeah
their friendship just that banter and
more like they seemed like they were
real friends yeah like they had such a
natural vacuum for us and they're both
funny
yeah they're both really quite yet and I
loved I loved his like taps talking when
you can try to give this enjoyed a scene
of these Filipino this guy yeah yeah
heck yeah I'm excited ability knobs are
finally getting into some movie dude
repeater in it right computer nation we
are we got the reject reject over 10
years from now it's is Megan I gonna be
a superhero I don't know I probably I
have no idea that leads we like him
enough we're going to give him powers
this is a trailer that showed you who is
buddy's over even that little snippet we
got with Michelle was a very nice but
yeah where are you going
enjoyed a dancer that so fun the
chemistry between his buddies and
keeping a secret in high school looks
very effective I guess I guess was
something that someone really
capitalizes on is
him having a secret in high school yeah
like having to go to school happens
which is hard it is hard only when
you're upon you today
yeah hell you know I bet he's not even
making anything yeah
seeing these scenes that I hope they
don't start releasing a bunch of seems
like more trailers like they did with
amazing spider-man 2 this was enough
this is the trailer that made me be like
eat and leave alright yeah weirdly that
was the trailer that actually amped up
my face and I even like the visit I
don't know if that's the final score for
the movie when he's crawling in and it's
like kind of synthy I like it yeah new
all right like oh this was the time to
make depression this is a darn good
spider-man homecoming
yeah I'm really I'm excited for those
scenes more than the other like yeah
exactly I'm like I can see a spider-man
cool even in spider-man 3 he has cool
stuff coming up later.this left an
impression on me and you guaranteed my
ticket yeah I'm good now like I don't
need a bunch more clips or anything or
see alright guys well hey subscribe to
the real rejects click that notification
belt check out our awesome patreon with
exclusive video content on there oh yeah
reads to Jerry on Twitter and Instagram
social media manager of Blum house
double toasted without the real real
Jerry Loven Zedd may miss a nugget area
I get a F